Okay, this is take number 14, tenuation of section 23.0 with Jack Schmidt.
Okay, flight data file is CSM.
Generally I have nothing but praise for the flight data file, both vehicles.
There was very, very few things that one could have asked for to improve that data file for the 4.17 at any rate.
One comment on the flight plane supplement.
We had split pages for a number of the logging, medical and food logging, and that probably was a mistake.
The idea was fairly good initially, but the pages we tended to only use that in the book as a whole, and it was a good place to keep them.
And also the pages, if you had wanted them split, were too thin to maintain the split and they tended to fall out of the book.
I would recommend either not splitting or having heavier paper, if you want them split.
We had an extra cue card built for panel 229.
I think it was an excellent card that summarized the circuit breaker functions, both on 229 and on panel eight.
Because we had no systems and anomalies of any significance that would relate to that card.
It was not used, but I would strongly recommend it's availability if only for training during the end or in Sims.
It's a good quick review of what you lose or retain for those two panels.
In the flight plan, I added some pen and ink cues along the margins for certain observational targets that I particularly wanted to look at.
These were independent of any designated experiment and entered them as a function of time.
That seemed to work very well for me.
I think it had that kind of thing as an individual preference item.
If you have experiment, it ought to be flight plan.
If you're just planning to use your spare time for specific observational targets or types of observations,
then I think the pen and ink is maybe the easiest way to go since it shouldn't concern any large number of people.
We, Gordy Fullerton, fixed up the circular orbital cue card for me with a similar designation of craters as a function of time.
I did not use that, not because it wasn't a good idea, but because of familiarity with the moon,
which came very quickly after a couple orbits.
You could recognize your position on the moon fairly easily as a function of each array of either the time and the red approximate time since sunset,
or just because you could look out the window and tell where you were.
In the limb, we, the same comments apply.
I think all the flight data file items were excellent.
I did not use the data card book to the extent that I'd always use on 15 and maybe on 16.
We log most of our specific items such as alignment data and comparable kinds of things in the checklist at the point where they were collected rather than in the data.
Book and had no, this did not seem to raise any difficulty at any time.
The cuff checklist, we've talked about, I think, in the surface items.
I thought the cuff checklist was excellent.
I think we did the things.
The right kind of photo maps in there that were useful for reference where we were around a given station.
I don't think we used them as much as I had anticipated using them, mainly because navigation was no problem.
In the points that we had selected preflight were excellent points for investigation and there was no need to try to decide on an alternative points to try to study in the vicinity of a given station.
The list of items to be accomplished at each station are to really they were mind joggers to read at each station.
We're not, again, not as used as much as I thought they would be initially, but I think that was mainly because we both at least I had become so familiar with the items that each station was in itself easy to recall.
As a result of having created the checklist, so the checklist was turned out to be more of a learning item rather than a reference item for use on the surface.
I wouldn't have done it any differently, however.
I particularly want to compliment the Chuck Lewis on the timeline book.
But I really can't say anything, but the timeline book was very, very well done and there had no problems with the timeline book at all.
But that, of course, applies to every checklist that we had.
There were just no procedural errors that I recall in any of the books that we used.
Fortunately, we didn't have to use an malfunction book.
I only, once did I pull out the systems data book to check on a systems problem and I, right now, I can't remember what that was.
I didn't remember where it was, or I didn't use it once.
The charts and maps, I thought in CSM that I would use the Orbiter Orbiter, what do they see?
Orbiter charts, I guess that's what they're called.
And I had an extra one put on, so I wouldn't interfere with the planned activities of the CMP.
I did not use that very much.
I eventually did some sketching on it, post DEI.
I think there are about five specific points that I labeled as areas, A, B, C, D, maybe E.
And these are referenced on my crew notebook, in my crew notebook for specific observations.
But in general, I did not put that to as much use as I expected.
One item is that that chart should have been identical to the CMP's chart.
And there were a few pen and ink changes left off of it that caused some confusion at one point.
And any exposure settings for certain photo targets.
The CSM, the landmark maps that the LNP had added in the rear of that book.
Again, we're not used.
I really thought I would use those, but in the, you became reluctant, as you were observing a specific point,
or area targets, they such as begin, or something like that, to take time out to sketch on the photo.
I tended for the two or three minutes that observation was possible of a given area.
I tended to look at the first opportunity to take notes in the notebook rather than trying to sketch on the photograph.
And I suspect that this was because I tended to look for generalizations about the target that I was trying to observe, rather than checking out specific individual features.
And they really did not seem to be any need to make notes about specific points on the pictures.
And as a result, I did not use them.
Again, though, I think having selected them and studied them pre-flight made it worth having them around.
The necessity for flying them was probably less than the necessity for having reviewed them and studied them.
I think I still, if I had to do it again, I still would want to have that kind of data available in the spacecraft, even though on this particular mission it was not used.
I do think, though, that the CMP used his visual target maps considerably, and I did in a couple occasions to use some of the ones that he had again.
But for the most part, that was post-tei, and I made some notes and sketches on some of those maps.
And I think that just a function that there was a lot of time to look at the moon and make a sketch and then look back and fix it up.
Post-tei, we're in orbit the time just to not exist.
As Dick Gordon said a couple years ago, and once you start flying, clock is relentless.
Okay, general flight planning.
I was not very closely involved in the flight planning run, sort of carried the burden of that.
For both Gene and myself, the flight plan was excellent.
We had no problems with it at all that I'm aware of.
Tommy Holloway and his people were to be complimented on that.
A number of different requirements and experiments and general operational items that were required to be integrated one with the other was very, very high.
was done in an extremely competent and usable way.
And I don't can't think of anything that I would change in the way the flight plan was written.
Okay, 23.5, preflight support.
Preflight support was excellent in the flight data file area and one specific item that I had was once the flight plan was well established.
Just about at the final stage, I had two or three texts I don't remember.
Two or three briefing sessions were in the portions of the orbit flight plan that I was going to be during which I would be in the spacecraft and the CSM.
We went over in detail the attitudes and maneuvers and the availability of the window availability so that I was able to plan in a very short amount of time with minimal effort on my part.
The my own personal observations of the lunar surface and which went very well as far as planning was concerned.
I appreciated that that was extra above and beyond the call of duty on the part of the flight planners and I appreciated their taking time out to do that for me.
I think it was useful to have the I think it was a day long session where the flight controllers and the crew and the flight planners sat around in one room and went over those portions of the flight plan which were not normally simulated.
It turned out that the flight planning had been so well done that I doubt if there were any specific items that came up that we need to do change or there was seem to be a lack of coordination on.
This was in contrast to previous lights were I think flights were I think we were still learning all of us were learning on how to put together flight plans and a great requirements of seven Apollo 17 flight plan apparently reached the peak of perfection.
I was a little bit disappointed in that briefing in that some of the people who would be eventually annually involved in the mission were not at the flight plan review.
I think this was because of of conflicts with other programs which were the center was carrying out at the time.
Okay 24.0 visual sightings.
Well we've covered the countdown and launch I think pretty well in the previous sections.
Also part flight earth orbit.
I think the transcript would cover the visual sightings that I made with respect to weather and a few geographic observations and that same would go for the fairly extensive weather observations that I tried to make.
Weather observations.
I don't know whether I recorded yet that although we had light flashes just to about continuously during a whole flight when you when you were dark adapted.
which I thought was a flash on the lunar surface during the first rev, that one period of time,
when we had the blindfolds on for the off-met experiment, there were no visible flashes,
although the next that evening, that night before I went to sleep, I noticed I was seeing the
light flashes again, so it just seemed to be that one interval either side of that, that interval
and either side of it were the light flash, and now I was not visible to myself, or to the other two
crewmen. I think the transcript and my crew notebook would cover all of visual sightings that
I can remember at this stage without going over to orbit by orbit and feature by feature with
the photography, I think that has to come later. Entry we covered in the previous briefings
and I think the same goes for landing and recovery, once just top of the second text.
25.0 permission planning for the LNP, it's hard to think once again of anything that we didn't do
right. I'm sure that might have been different had we had problems on the flight, but right the way
the flight went, the total plan, the integration of the mission requirements into that plan.
Although there were periods of some difficulty, pre-flight, particularly in the area of medical
requirements, and in some last minute possible scientific requirements, particularly on the samples,
everything seemed to get resolved satisfactorily in years I could tell, and I can't think of
of anything that was not handled very well between the people who were leveling the requirements
and the flight planners in particular, and occasionally when the crew had to be involved, that
was handled almost entirely by the support crew of Bob Parker and the science area and
the course of our training period, Ron, I guess the biggest single area that took time was
one that Ron had to deal with and that was a lunar sounder. Most of our outset changes were
taken care of prior to our training and we had a few minor suggestions that were taken care of
early in the training cycle and we essentially had an up-to-date outset to train with
and all other lunar surface gear was up-to-date for most of the 12-month training period.
By the final 12 months of the training period, mission rules and techniques were fairly well defined
very early by Phil Schaeffer and his crowd in the techniques area and the mission rules
during Jerry Griffin and people working on that. No major changes and only the only changes were
all I felt in the right direction and that they enhanced the probability of making a landing
in a successful mission. They openly were in the area of opening up possibilities for work
around so that a mission could be completed. We really never had to exercise any significant
mission rules in a normal way. I think the one time that mission rule tended to
let me finish this check. A mission rule tended to be fairly clearly a controlling factor was in
the limitation on the work at station four or shorty crater where we were up against the walk
back constraints and terminated that work after only 35 minutes were another 30 minutes there
I think would have been extremely valuable although I hope that we got enough information that
the phenomena exposed that that crater can be understood.
26.0 mission control typically outstanding support for mission control.
I think the this includes the number of extracurricular hours that the limb people and the e-cons
for the CSM in particular put in with me on Saturdays and other times just generally talking over
systems and techniques mission rules and that was a major factor in helping me understand and
keep up to speed on the on those items. I think the help that they gave me and designing and
in fact as I essentially did it did the design of the emergency cue cards that we did for
Apollo 17 for the limb or was a major contribution although fortunately not we did not use them they
still made it possible to understand very quickly systems problems and to solve those problems
in the simulations and had we require them I think it would have gone very well.
26.0
Particularly one of the point out the help that Dick Thorson gave in organizing most of the limb sessions
and even some of the joint CSM limb sessions that we had.
26.0
And he also Thorson also was a major organizer of the creation of and the updating of Bill's emergency cue cards.
Even factors 27.0
Let's go back. That's one other comment of 26.0.
Both flight it's my understanding that some of the things I had hoped could be done during the flight were not possible because of
real-time discussions in the mission control.
Specifically one of those things was to have some summary of the thinking of the science background
given to me while in flight and that would be the thinking based on the data that we had transmitted to them
verbally and to since visually through the television camera.
I had hoped that I would have the benefit of their thinking but apparently this was not possible to do.
I would like to think that in the future we can look at ways of using the team approach to science investigations
in space rather than depending solely on the observational capability and the interpreted capability of the men who are performing the job.
There's no reason that I can see to not use all the brainpower that's available for any given task and part of that brainpower is on the ground.
Okay 27.0
Human factors, pre-flight.
The broad of the discussions and organization from the crew point of view of the pre-flight health stabilization control program was born by the commander and the LNP just sort of went along with whatever was decided.
I personally did not find any great difficulty in working out and adhering to the requirements of that program.
I think medical care, all very limited requirement was good but a couple of sinus infections I had reacted just like they always had and we were able over a period of ten days or two weeks to get those cleared up.
Time for exercise probably was less than it should have been although I was able to get a good workout just about every other day in addition to the workouts we got as a normal course of our EBA training.
Eventually texts started scheduling putting on the schedule time in the late afternoon for exercise and that helped as a reminder and buffer to see that exercise was obtained.
It is generally hard and at least in the lunar training program to get exercise periods in during the day and quite frequently the exercise was done in the Cape Gym at night.
I think rest and sleep is an individual thing and I made a particular effort to always get as much as I possibly could and try never to get behind the park or on rest because my personal experiences that that is when I tend to get coals and resulting sinus infections.
Medical briefing was good.
The exams seemed to go very well in my estimation.
They were as expeditious as possible under the circumstances.
I think the operational medical personnel who carried out the exams are to be complemented in their efforts to see that the exam was as painless and as efficient as possible.
This should also include the post flight exams on the Ticonderoga.
Eating habits and amount of food consumption were normal except during those periods of time when we were on the in-flight food prior to launch.
And those times that attended the in my case a decrease of appetite and certainly although the food was certainly palatable.
My appetite did go down and it was not possible for me to eat the amount of food that was provided for me.
This also applied to space work but in the case of the in-flight eating although I did not eat everything that was available to me in my food packages I apparently should need it to if I hadn't wanted to avoid losing weight.
My appetite was down but also apparently for some reason I had a loss of weight and at this time of this recording my way to still down is not going up to pre-flight levels which may have been a little high by the way.
Okay and 17.2 flight appetite food preference well I just discussed that a little bit and the appetite in-flight versus to each pre-flight was less again except for when we were testing the pre-flight food when I also had a low appetite.
No notable differences in the taste of food I think the things I like pre-flight I liked in space and the things I didn't like I also didn't like I didn't notice any differences.
Changing food preferences of flight progressed I tended to start to prefer to eat the wet packs and would eat those in preference to any of the other solid foods.
I would strongly recommend my personal point of view at any rate that the wet packs be used in preference to the rehydrateable.
I know I think that probably you get a different opinion from the other crewmen.
After the first period of one and only period of difficulty with loose bowel movements I did cut out the potassium indicated foods and I can't say whether that had any effect or not but I did not have any other bowel movements and certainly no more loose ones before the end of the flight.
The first bowel movement after flight on a tight time the roger was normal.
The second was very loose, the third was normal and the fourth and fifth very loose.
The size of food portions and the meal portions of course were pretty much constant in terms of availability.
My appetite was very low the first day and gradually increased over the next two or three days and remained essentially the same after about the third day.
I mentioned the most acceptable foods with the wet packs and the juices.
The food cake I thought was good although it was possible to eat too much or to get to the point where you didn't want anymore.
The chocolate was good.
I think of the dry crackers or cookies or graham crackers were probably the most tasty.
And peanut butter and jelly sandwiches were quite good.
Deviations from the menu and the periods are all recorded in the flight transcript I'm sure.
Food preparation and consumption.
The rehydration went phenomenally and the normal gas was present.
Food temperature tended to prefer the foods that were warm or hot and the hot water was quite adequate for warm foods.
We actually missed the warm foods considerably in the limb where the hot water was not available.
I did not notice an effect of water flavor or water was reasonably tasty.
I never noticed a high chlorine taste of any kind.
The gas content did make it a little bit uncomfortable to eat at times.
Boom bowl packages worked pretty well although those were finally divided.
I tended to cut off the other end of the package.
The water insertion end and use them as a squeeze package.
Spoons worked perfectly adequate.
I attended not to use the fruit in the cans because of just the messiness of opening them.
Those although I think the technique that Ron worked out was opening it in your inner ear mouth is a good one.
It was only the fruits, canned fruits that I tended to avoid just because they were inconvenient to use.
Food bars, near any EVAs, I think were good to have although I never ate more than half of one.
It wasn't because it was untasteier just because of maybe a lack of interest in eating and using that time during the EVAs.
I think after the EVA, before and after the EVAs and the limb ate very well.
There were some things though we avoided and I guess in my case, after one having corn chowder once and it's simulating a major problem at although not a loose one.
I did not eat corn chowder, I did not eat the cocoa, we could have tended to feel like I got a little more gas from cocoa.
After taste I did not eat the shrimp.
The seafood, the item shrimp and the lobster biscuit and these sort of things.
Because of pre-flight I had noticed that they tended to have a long after taste.
But otherwise I think all the other foods were certainly acceptable.
I know many times I did not eat potato based foods because of just they were very filling.
Food, waste, storage.
I don't know how the German side old tablet worked.
The pouch was okay.
It would have been nice to have a little dispenser that was easier to use than the pouch.
I don't know whether that would be possible to do or not.
It seems to me it would a little tube dispenser of some kind where they came out more easily.
You didn't tend to.
We generally just cut the corner off the pouch and squeezed them out but it was little inconvenient.
No, nothing major.
We used the German side old tablets.
I did in all the juice bags and the food spoon bowl bags and the wet packs.
I did not use them in the tea and coffee.
Under the zebra holders really except for the passing of gas occasionally by the other crewmen and some occasionally by myself.
Under the zebra holders were the minimum I did not define that the atmosphere was unpleasant as a general rule.
I might say that I generally had a continuous, almost continuous passage of gas, most of which apparently was not significant older.
The only occasionally that seemed to be objectionable to the other crewmen.
I think most of that was the water gas.
The reason I think that is that upon eating, upon starting to eat, it would be increased design at a pass gas.
Increased pressure in my stomach apparently was transmitted almost immediately into the bowels.
I would after eating it would pass gas for a couple hours to three hours.
Just before eating the next time, the desire would have pretty well dissipated and then it would start again immediately upon eating.
Before any digestion was possible, I am sure, so I suspect water gas was the main culprit in the E.L.M.P.'s gas problem, which were not significant.
The quantity of food eaten on the lunar surface I think was high, although probably no more than half of that food that was available.
It's hard to say exactly and I think that could be worked out.
Maybe with a detailed look at the menus if that is desirable.
And to estimate the quantity would be very difficult.
Food quantity of food discarded on the lunar surface would be difficult without looking at the detail menus and checking off those items that I am sure we ate at I.E.D. anyway.
It's not a lot of fecal content.
We use the blue bag.
The blue bag is not a bad way to defecate unless the stool is loose.
If it's loose, it's just about impossible to use.
And I don't know what you do in zero-gravity.
For loose stools, I don't know of any clever way to prevent that being a problem.
And I'm not even sure whatever this trial I have for people who are using will prevent that from being a problem.
The best thing you can do is to work out prevention of loose stools rather than trying to handle them after you get them.
It is.
The loose stool is one of the major hygiene and sanitary and operational problems that you can have on a flight.
I can't emphasize that more.
If it happened on a regular basis on a daily basis, you would eventually cut the efficiency of the crew member with the problem by a significant percentage.
Possibly as much as 30 percent depending on the magnitude of the problem.
I think it's important to try to understand why Apollo 17 was different than 16 and at least in the delay of a problem of loose stools until about the 11th or 12th day.
And in the case of the commander, no problem of loose stools and my personal opinion at this point based on very little information other than observation in flight and thinking about levels of the electrolyte intake.
With the electrolyte quantity down from that imposed on Apollo 16 that we did not reach the electrolyte saturation level until the 11th or 12th day.
In terms of this CMP and the LMP and in terms of the commander because his electrolyte intake was generally less.
I think that can be documented.
He did not reach the saturation level at all.
And when that saturation level was reached our, in the case of the CMP and LMP, I suspect that the electrolytes we were eating were dumped in a sense or concentrated in the intestines intended to act pretty much as a laxity.
And as an epsilon type laxity, if you will, in concentrated water in the stool.
I think it's important for Skyline out that first of all we probably reduced the electrolyte intake so that saturation is never reached.
And secondly that if loose stool problem develops it appears to be an electrolyte problem other than any other biological problem that we decrease the intake of electrolytes.
And this is what I did on my own and whether or not it worked or not it's hard to say because the flight was terminated before any other stools occurred.
So it's a parent to me except during chlorination.
Iodontation odor is very slight apparent in the limb water but not not have any significance to the LMP.
No physical discomfort for the LMP other than tiredness on occasion and in the case of the EVA work sore muscles and the bruises under the fingernails.
Elsewhere, I tend to see a thirst during the mission never really thirst the extensively thirst even during the EVA so although I did stop to take a drink of water occasionally.
But I never drunk, I never drank all the water in the in-flight drink bag in suit drink bag.
Work rest and sleep.
Okay.
Hey, Tex.
Could you try to call the.
Call the trailer was I work rest sleep for the LMP.
Okay.
The difficulty in going to sleep was variable and when seeking always used generally no difficulty in going to sleep.
When it was not used I guess there was a tendency to stay awake a little bit longer but on other occasions the.
The after seeking all did not seem to affect the rate of going to sleep.
There was a tendency on a couple on several nights to go to sleep and then wake up fairly soon after going to sleep within an hour.
And then the second time took a little bit.
Not maybe sometimes took up to an hour to go back to sleep.
But I feel that the medical law reports that for the LMP were generally valid that a probably average five and a half to six hours of sleep per night was good and I don't think except for maybe one night somewhere in there.
Did I go much below that but the sleep was rarely contained probably never continuous for more than.
Three hours without waking up.
I feel that six hours is as adequate sleep for the kind of work we were doing in space.
However the programming of eight hours is necessary in order to get six hours because of the.
Periods of wakefulness when during sleep periods and for just the difficulty in getting the cabin organized and everybody to bed at the pride program time.
So maintaining an eight hour sleep period is I think mandatory in order to obtain the six hours.
That is probably all that is required to to perform the mission.
Without getting tired or getting behind the park or say with respect to sleep.
I had the feeling that fine by the way.
I had the feeling that I wanted to have my head.
And limbs restrained in order to get a good sleep although I did sleep at times without without that restraint.
I if I were rebuilding the sleeper strain set for my personal use I would make them smaller with somewhat more.
A feeling of restraint there a little bit large I would say for for use.
When I slept in the couch I tended to put a shoulder strap over my head and since down very likely so that I had that feeling of head restraint.
Probably the biggest two things that made sleep difficult.
When it was difficult was the loss of century perception of limb position in zero gravity when when they were not being moved that perception came back immediately upon moving them.
But when they were just static and in a rest position they tended to be from for the LNP at any way the loss of century perception of the position of the limb.